[Music]
a shabby man named Estragon sits near a
tree at dusk and struggles to remove his
boot he soon joined by his friend
Vladimir who reminds his anxious
companion that they must wait here for
someone called gada so begins a vexing
cycle in which the to debate when goda
will come why they're waiting and
whether they're even at the right tree
from here waiting for Godot only gets
stranger but it's considered a play that
changed the face of modern drama written
by Samuel Beckett between 1949 and 1955
it offers a simple but stirring question
what should the characters do don't us
do anything is safer let's wait and see
what he says oh god oh good idea
such cryptic dialogue and circular
reasoning a key features of the theatre
of the absurd a movement which emerged
after the Second World War and found
artists struggling to find meaning in
devastation the absurdists deconstructed
plot character and language to question
their meaning and share their profound
uncertainty on stage while this may
sound grim the absurd blends its
hopelessness with humor this is
reflected in Beckett's unique approach
to genre in Waiting for Godot which he
branded a tragic comedy in two acts
tragically the characters are locked in
an existential conundrum they wait in
vain for an unknown figure to give them
a sense of purpose but their only sense
of purpose comes from the act of waiting
while they wait they sink into boredom
Express religious dread and contemplates
suicide but comically there is a jagged
humor to their predicament which comes
across in their language and movements
their interactions are filled with
bizarre wordplay repetition and deublin
tone as well as physical clowning
singing and dancing and frantically
swapping their hat
it's often unclear whether the audience
is supposed to laugh or cry or whether
Beckett saw any difference between the
two born in Dublin Beckett studied
English French and Italian before moving
to Paris where he spent most of his life
writing theater poetry in prose while
Beckett had a lifelong love of language
he also made space for silence by
incorporating gaps pauses and moments of
emptiness into his work this was a key
feature of his trademark uneven tempo
and black humour which became popular
throughout the theatre of the absurd he
also cultivated a mysterious persona and
refused to confirm or deny any
speculations about the meaning of his
work this kept audiences guessing
increasing their fascination with his
surreal worlds and enigmatic characters
the lack of any clear meaning makes
godoh endlessly open to interpretation
critics have offered countless readings
of the play resulting in a cycle of
ambiguity and speculation that mirrors
the plot of the drama itself it's been
read as an allegory of the Cold War the
French Resistance and Britain's
colonization of Ireland the dynamic of
the two protagonists has also sparked
intense debate they've been read as
survivors of the apocalypse an aging
couple two impotent friends and even as
personifications of Freud's
ego and EDD famously Beckett said the
only thing he could be sure of was that
Vladimir and Estragon were wearing
bowler hats like the critical
speculation and maddening plot their
language often goes in circles as the
two bicker and banter lose their train
of thought and pick up right where they
left off we could start all over again
perhaps I should be easy
it's the start that's difficult but you
can start from anything yes but you have
to decide
Beckett reminds us that just like our
daily lives the world on stage doesn't
always make sense it can explore both
reality and illusion the familiar and
the strange and although a tidy
narrative still appeals the best theatre
keeps us thinking and waiting well we
have you why not plunge into an
existential vortex with this playlist or
shake it off with a good old-fashioned
cat video
[Music]